[Musique
] Hier soir, j'étais là à le
regarder surveiller sur une caméra avec Linda
Hamilton et sur une autre caméra était
Arnold Schwarzenegger Je pensais que
[ __ ] de merde je fais un film Terminator ouais la
chimie a capturé ce ton c'est r-rated
c'est sinistre c'est graveleux
c'est rapide, son look intense et
dur et c'est ce que ce film était
sur la vision fraîche de Jane Estes et comme
ce qu'il a fait en profondeur dans son action,
c'est juste un tour rapide et
tu ferais mieux de regarder ton cul je chasse les
terminateurs
[ __ ] de métal mais suit tonalement les traces donc
t1 et t2 cette montée d'adrénaline ressentant
ce sentiment de terreur dans ce film l'
action est dix fois plus grande c'est comme de
la merde sacrée merde sacrée merde sacrée ce film
est implacable il ne s'arrête pas
juste [ __ ] d'insecte
vous